hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Article 5 of question 46 of
sumateologia Prima secunde Thomas
Aquinas is going to ask a very
interesting question
is anger era more natural natural
than desire concupis cantia right so
there's a comparison here of anger and
desire going on and you can sort of
figure out the reasoning for this if you
know some Aristotle as he's going to
mention in the on the other hand are the
said Contra part there is Aristotle's
statement anger is more natural than
desire which Aristotle is going to make
in the discussion
of the difference between losing
controller lack of control with respect
to desire for bodily pleasures and doing
so motivated by anger and so Aristotle
statement is not necessarily intended to
be a blanket statement and as we're
going to see Thomas does think that in
some ways anger is more natural and in
other ways desire or appetite or however
you want to express it is more natural
so he starts out by looking at three
possible Arguments for why desire would
be in every case more natural and the
first one has to do with human beings
being more natural being more naturally
gentle animals right it says proprium so
what is distinctive to human beings is
said to be to be a man animal Monsoon to
be a gentle Animal by Nature now that's
kind of a strange statement but what
could you argue from that well then
anger is going against our nature as he
says it seems to be completely
contrary to human nature well in that
case anger is kind of an aberration
right and desire would be more natural
then because it's some something that we
experience
in the second argument he's going to
rely on a distinction which we might not
in the Modern Age completely understand
or recognize just from how he's saying
it he tells us that we distinguish right
or more properly we divide things into
reason
and
nature right so we make a distinction as
he says between
acting according to reason and acting
according to Nature and now this is
something that in the medievals we see
reflected there is this entire world of
nature that was created by God and
everything has its own nature that it
acts according to except for things that
have on the one hand reason and on the
hand on the other hand
will and specifically a will capable of
free choice things of that sort are said
to be of the rational order they could
choose to do otherwise like fire can't
help but burn but if you've got a fire
you can burn things with it or cook
things with it or put it out right you
have choices and so if that's the case
then
um he says that in the ethics we read
anger obeys reason desire does not so
again invoking Aristotle so again desire
more natural than anger
the third one is very interesting he
says anger is a craving or literally an
appetite for vengeance well the emotion
of Desire uh concupiscantia is a craving
for pleasures of Touch Above All again
where is this coming from from Aristotle
right Aristotle's discussion in the nick
of McCann ethics and he says namely for
food and for sex matters
so he says that these are more natural
to a human being than vengeance is
therefore desire is going to be more
natural than anger so we've got three
Arguments for saying anger okay it could
be natural to some degree but desire is
way more natural than that and then
Thomas says after invoking Aristotle
well we need to think about this in
terms of causes
so he says what is naturally produced
what is produced through nature naturale
is
um called natural as is clear from
Aristotle's physics and so he says only
considering the causes can determine
whether an emotion is more or less
natural so notice he's willing to say
that some emotions could be more natural
than others
so how do we make sense of this he says
well we need to consider it in terms of
its object what it is that it's aiming
at right what it's intended towards and
the subject the subjectum the being that
the emotion is taking place in now
here's where it gets very interesting
because Thomas is willing to say listen
if we think in terms of the object
actually anger is less natural than
desire is why is that the case he says
desire particularly the desire for food
and venereal pleasure sexual pleasure is
more natural than anger because these
are more natural than what is what is
aimed for at anger the objectum the
object Revenge vindication
what about in terms of the subject
so here he makes a very interesting
uh distinction he says that when we're
thinking about anger in the terms of the
subject in one sense anger is more
natural and in another sense desire is
why is this because human nature can be
understood in three different ways three
different levels you could say so at the
highest level of generality we've got
the generic we are animals right and
then we have the species Humanity what
is distinctive about the species
rationality and then each one of us as
an individual person has our own and we
could translate it in various ways our
own temperament our own makeup our own
you know way of being in the world
um you know secundum proprium complexion
each of us has a complexio literally how
things are folded together so if we
think about it in terms of the generic
as an Anna them all he says that um
desire is more natural than anger then
why by reason of our generic nature a
human being is inclined to desire what
will conserve life either one's own or
that of the race we have a natural
inclination when he talks about the
natural law this is something that he
appeals to and food and sex are you
could say more common and natural ways
of carrying out that inclination so
they're in some way more natural than
seeking out revenge or Vindication but
when we get to the level of the species
we're no longer looking at human being
as just an animal but uh the rational
animal
here Thomas will say anger is more
natural to us us human beings than is
desire why because there's more
rationality there's more reason involved
in Anger than in desire so Aristotle
actually is going to say and Thomas
follows him here that revenge or uh you
know imposing some sort of vindication
on the other person is more human than
gentleness so even though we might be
said to be a gentle animal we actually
are more prone to anger than to
gentleness and I think this is borne out
in many respects he says it's natural
for anything to be aroused against
what's hostile and threatening and you
could actually read between the lines
and say yeah those human beings they see
lots and lots of things as hostile and
threatening it's part of their uh common
you know life their common nature and
then he says if we're thinking about a
given individual right
in terms of their unique temperament
right again secundum proprium
complexionum
then uh again anger is more natural than
desire why he says anger is easily
aroused as a result of a natural
temperamental inclination to
erascability irascability is the
tendency to get angry the disposition he
actually uses the word dispositus here
um so you know the disposition to get
angry why and here he makes an appeal to
a medical theory that we don't really
buy into anymore that of the different
humors he says an irascible disposition
is characteristic of a choleric
temperament some people are just more
irascible because they have more black
bile within their system and Kohler is
more quickly aroused than the other
humors than say blood or limb for spleen
or any of those sorts of things it's
said to be like fire fire is much more
easily aroused so
if you're the kind of person who has
this temperament of irascability then
anger is in a certain respect more
natural to you is this saying that it's
natural to everybody in this way no he's
not claiming that he is just saying you
know we've already got the human species
anger is more natural but some people
are even more
prone to that you could say
now
he has a lengthy discussion of the first
argument human beings right Art by
nature are supposed to be gentle and he
says that we can consider human beings
in in two different ways we can think
about how our bodies work and how the
humors come together the complexio of
those things are temperament and then we
can think about our rationality so if we
consider it in terms of our makeup or
temperament then the human being is
actually kind of a balanced Animal by
contrast to the other animals which go
this way or this way or this way we have
kind of an equilibrium or a balance or a
Harmony between these things so he says
a human being is not naturally and
essentially endowed with an overpowering
disposition either to anger or any other
emotion the other animals lack this
constitutional equilibrium so it's
natural for them to be excess
excessively inclined to a particular
emotion he uses dog as an example of an
animal that is inclined to anger
interestingly enough to era and so you
know the human being is in that respect
could be gentle or could be angry right
but he says as far as his rationality is
concerned it is natural for a human
being to become both to become angry
right
but also to be gentle both of them are
possibilities for us and he says on the
one hand anger may be called for by
reason reasons reason realizes that
there's a threat that needs to be
protected against and on the other hand
reason can subdue anger so you know is
this saying this argument is completely
wrong no but it's it's responding to it
in a very interesting way the second one
right saying that there's a distinction
between the the rational and the natural
well our nature is to be rational right
that is what is uh our species we are
the rational animal so this distinction
making an argument based on this
distinction is just not going to really
work so he says from the fact that anger
is accompanied by an act of reason it
follows in some sense anger is natural
to the human being so when we're
considering you know what is whether
anger is more natural less natural right
for us human beings it is at least in
this respect more natural and then for
the third argument he actually says the
argument deals with anger and desire in
terms of their object obviously in terms
of the object desire is more natural
fine will concede that so what we've got
here is some very interesting
Reflections on how natural anger is to
us human beings in comparison to desire
for for bodily pleasures
and it's using this three-fold
distinction between
ways in which we can talk about our
nature we have a generic nature we have
a specific nature then we have a unique
temperament as individual human beings